already controversial ethiopia has
started generating power from its
renaissance dam what does it mean for
negotiations between neighbouring
countries who stands to gain or lose
this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the show i'm sami
zaydan ethiopia has begun generating
power from its grand ethiopian
renaissance dam
with the new source of clean electricity
addis ababa hopes to charge its economic
development but the project is not
sitting well downstream the giant
hydropower dam is built on the upper
part of the blue nile river
it's been a source of controversy from
the time the first brick was laid a
decade ago
for sudan and egypt the nile river's
waters are a lifeline for millions both
governments say the dam threatens their
access to water and are demanding a
legally binding agreement to protect
their interests
ethiopia's prime minister ahmed says
there's nothing to worry about he calls
the dam an opportunity for all countries
in the region
the downstream countries the brothers
the people of egypt and sudan the water
will flow and the world must know that
the dam will not affect them
all that was said about ethiopia seeking
to prevent the flow of water is untrue
and we will not allow the people to
starve or thirst
these are our principles and our
position and we affirm the flow of water
to the people from the dam is to develop
and bring 60 million ethiopians out of
the darkness we seek integration between
the three countries and a real
partnership
well commenting on ethiopia's
announcement the egyptian foreign
affairs ministry issued a statement
saying
after the previous unilateral start of
the first and second stages of filling
the dam the arab republic of egypt
affirms this step is a further violation
by the ethiopian side of its obligations
under the 2015 principles agreement
signed by the ethiopian prime minister
we'll begin our discussion in a moment
but first let's bring you up to speed on
africa's largest hydroelectric project
construction was started in 2011
under the late former prime minister
melis civil servants contributed one
month's salary towards the project for
its launch the government has since
issued dam bonds aimed at ethiopians at
home and abroad
the cost of the grand ethiopian
renaissance dam is estimated to be close
to five billion dollars by harnessing
the force of water ethiopia aims to
provide electricity for 70 percent of
its people
many of them don't have electricity at
all
filling the dam's vast reservoir began
in 2020 hitting a target of 4.9 billion
cubic meters by july that year
prime minister abby ahmed says the
project is scheduled for completion in
2024
[Music]
let's bring in our guests we have
joining us from the hague adam casey
abbey he's the program officer at the
international institute for democracy
and electoral assistance in london we
have alam ahmed president of the world
association for sustainable development
and in somerville alex duvall is
executive director at the world peace
foundation welcome to you all if i could
start with adam so does the beginning of
uh operations at this time indicate the
project is on track and heading for
success
um absolutely the the project has been
on track for for a while now it has been
delayed and it has generated a lot of
extra costs and of course it has been
politicized
but it's making steady progress
alan will the project complete as
expected in 2024 will it produce
i think it's like more than five
thousand megawatts of electricity how's
it looking i think
the question of completion uh no one can
know the answer for that because
uh there's lots of issues going on with
uh there's lots of legal challenges the
land is service still disputed uh and
the situation in both uh sudan and
isubia is not settling down
so it's a big question mark but uh at
least now we have seen the production of
one turbine producing megawatts so
it is on on track to produce and to
complete but when is quite a big
question no one really can tell
particularly no one knows the technical
uh what is going on in that dam really
is quite difficult to tell no one has
seen the the
the engineering
if you like paperwork of that damn yet
all right but now it is switched on alex
is it giving us any clearer clues about
its impact on other countries
i think that really remains to be seen i
think prime minister abi ahmed was
absolutely correct in saying that there
is no reason why
the operation of the dam should affect
the downstream stream countries in fact
it could be to their advantage because
it can regulate the flow better because
it's a hydroelectric dam is not actually
using water for irrigation
and and so the the flow should be
unimpeded and should be better regulated
and because the water is stored at a
high altitude in the ethiopian highlands
there will be less evaporation than in
the
lowland
lakes of of northern sudan
and egypt that said
the context in which the dam is becoming
operational is very different
to the context in which it was conceived
10 years ago it was the brainchild of
the late mellow scenario it was the
jewel in the crowd crown of the
developmental stage and the reason it's
called the renaissance dam is that that
is a shout out to the principles of the
african renaissance the idea that the
african states should
band together for collective development
for integration for cooperation now what
has happened since then is two
transformations first of all the
developmental state has been abandoned
and and and reversed and and there is a
big question mark over the economic
future of of of ethiopia and secondly
the political and diplomatic context has
been transformed so that instead of
ethiopia being embedded in an alliance
of of african nations that actually put
egypt something in a and something of a
diplomatic corner
um what has happened is is that lance
has been dismantled by prime minister
abby um including
resulting in the antag antagonism that
exists between ethiopia and sudan and
ethiopia is now becoming very dependent
on its middle eastern patrons for money
and weapons notably the united arab
emirates so it's a very different
political context in which there's a lot
of turmoil and a lot of distrust all
right so it is changing more than just
uh the developmental situation for
ethiopia and the region how
adam how will the operation of the first
turbine do you think how will it impact
that deadlock in talks between ethiopia
on the one hand and sudan and egypt on
the other
um so one one point to add to what alex
dewald said
he is right that the context has changed
fundamentally um but the ethiopian
position the ethiopian idea towards the
dam and how relevant it is and then also
how it perceives it will affect
downstream countries hasn't really
changed the context has indeed changed
but how the damned self is perceived and
the interest and desire to see it to
completion hasn't um that is one in
terms of you know how the the the dam
and the the progress that has been made
can can change relations perhaps it's
important to say that if you look at how
the three countries have approached this
particular relationship it's it's
perhaps a reflection of how they see the
politics in their or in their own
countries the politics in each of these
countries is often founded on mistrust
um it is founded on uh
sort of winner textual
politics and sometimes even of of
conflict dominance and so that mistrust
that we see at the domestic level in
each of these countries is actually
reflected uh in their relationships with
each other
how will that impact the distrust is
this going to encourage countries to at
least start resuming talks or all the
opposite
well it is necessary they have to talk i
mean they have differences it's
important to note that they have made a
lot of progress there's two key issues
whether there's still a lot of
stickiness uh particularly in terms of
how in case of a an an you know an
unfortunate draw situation how the water
will be managed particularly on the
duties of ethiopia to let go of the
water and even some you know some of the
the stored water and also in terms of
how in case there are disputes in terms
of the principle of equitable
distribution of water one of uh causing
no significant harm can be can be
resolved
but they have to talk it's necessary
and and the progress they have made so
far i think you know despite the fact
that there has not been any major
breakthroughs they have actually worked
together and there is a sense of
developing trust among these countries
um and so i i think let me bring in alex
it offers a possibility for
transformation do you agree with that is
there a sense of progress being made i
mean when you look at the history
of these talks it seems like the parties
are stuck on some of the same points
drought management third-party
arbitration
and
future adjustments to the agreement
they've been arguing over that for years
haven't they
yes that's correct and i think the the
key issue here to remind my
your viewers here uh estebia has been
playing the politics uh quite if you
like uh sophisticated here
uh number one in the last two years uh
if you remember all of you uh esubia
have used the opportunity they're very
opportunistic i know this might sound
negative but it's true
when is eubie finds or found sudan in
the last two years in serious trouble
internally
they try to maximize anything uh
dramatically will not be recovered
reverse easily
sudan has been going through a very
difficult time i think frankly speaking
sudan has no government as we speak so
there is no one at all telling or even
talking to the esopian now because we
don't have a government incident
secondly ethiopia you can see the way
abraham is talking now he's talking
about more of
akira someone who really take care of
sudan and egypt i'm talking about it's
not going to affect them he's he's
changing the tone if you look last year
and the year before the tone was more of
threatening we will do what we want now
is more of don't worry it will not
affect you it will regulate water and so
on number three also the geopolitics of
the region has also changed i agree with
alex if you can see the american envoy
to the region he's now more of residing
in isubia rather than and he just make
visit to sudan so they have somehow
behind closed door which we all don't
know
uh the american are quite significant
there and i agree also is alex the
involvement of emirates united arab
emirates is also changing the the game
now in this uh disputed area but to go
back to your question about the history
we have been here before
there are things we continue to be
standing out number one egyptians
relying almost 90 something percent 97
on this water of the night so it's for
them it's a survival issue the same this
european they see it as a survival
project the egyptian they see the water
from the line at the survival project
egyptian have managed
to integrate very well with europe and
they are exporting in london i go to
supermarket i buy lots of fruits and
vegetables from egypt so egyptian cannot
take any risk on that agricultural
productivity to be hindered or being
affected it's a serious talk here right
sadly if you follow last month's the
egyptian prime minister was urging
isubian again to sign a binding
agreement or any legal documents euban
didn't sudan in the bus have been asking
for any technical
uh
if you like uh sharing about what is
going because you can't keep
saying it's not going to affect sudan
it's going to regulate the water okay we
have experts from sudan
but they want to see this documentation
i am an expert in in water why not you
show me i have my
my engineers show them more finally we
haven't seen any independent evaluation
i have been and many others calling
internationally for an independent
technical review of the damn makeup and
there is not a single independent review
so this all make it as a classic example
i'm just bringing the last that points
to mission
it's a survival project right and
there's clearly there's a lot of
progress that still needs to be made in
addressing the same points what is the
bottom line alex does hitting the on
button of the dam
make the chances of conflict less likely
or more likely do you think
i think the
the two issues that need clearly to be
separated here one is the the technical
issue and
in principle technically speaking the
dam is a win-win situation it it it can
make the water management of the nile
basin more rational to the
advantage of all the riparian countries
especially in the context of
climate change and and the greater
fluctuations in in rainfall and and
river levels there's no doubt about that
the real problem is one of trust
and the the the egyptians understand the
the technical issues perfectly well
their concern is that in the case of
of a political dispute for some other
reason between ethiopia and egypt
ethiopia now has in its hands a weapon
it can actually block the flow of the
nile should it want to and that is the
the existential question and no treaty
no no signature on on on on a piece of
paper is going to be sufficient
to persuade the egyptians that
there are no circumstances under which
ethiopia will will not use that ultimate
weapon as it were
can there be any solution to that
sense of vulnerability
has really shifted which is that
ethiopia today is much much weaker than
it was a few years ago because it has
become diplomatically much weaker weaker
but above all because it's economically
weaker the country is in a a major
economic crisis
um with its its bonds trading as junk
with a practically drying up of a
foreign direct investment bad relations
with all its a donors facing a major
food crisis this year
and and i i'm sure that is the number
one explanation why abi ahmed has tried
to reconcile with the americans whom he
was condemning just a few months ago
while he went cap in hand to the um
european union a you african union
summit just recently
and and and while he why he is also
adopting this conciliatory language he
needs the money and he and he
understands that this is a good and this
approach this much more conciliatory
approach is is is a way of getting that
and it may well work out to the
advantage of all adam it sounds like
listening to our other guests that
really this may continue to be a source
of conflict and
a source of generating fear for sudan
and egypt no matter
what guarantees on paper the ethiopians
are or are not willing to give
um well i think so you know first it's
important to recognize that the
egyptians the sudanese
have genuine interest in what in what is
happening in the in the building of the
dam and its oppressions i think that's
very important um but secondly it's also
important to recognize that abu yahmad
uh when he came to power the first thing
he did was actually travel to egypt and
assure them that there will not be any
consequence any significant harm to
their interests or so to say that
abu yahama essentially sweet talking
them now because the country is in
trouble um is is i think uh is is it
missed the point uh that that's one and
secondly um you are right and i think
that's the point i was trying to make
earlier was that the countries in terms
of how they relate to each other
has been defined by the same kind of
mistrust and winner takes over politics
that characterize their politics at home
um and as they're making progress now
and as i say there's there has not been
any breakthrough and there are still
certain important sticky points
but the only way to develop trust is
actually to work together um and the
only way also to prevent a scenario that
alex spoke about where ethiopia could
essentially
essentially block the dumb is to connect
the countries even more i think
the nile is it's a geographic it's a
historical um
umbilical cord that connects the country
and it potentially can transform not
just the relationship around the river
itself but the relationship among the
countries and i think only that that
integration will guarantee that's the
safest bet for for for egypt otherwise
even if there is an agreement um in the
scenario that ethiopia wants uh to hurt
egypt it could still violate that
particular agreement so i think it's not
a written agreement as important as that
is uh it's not that that will prevent
any damage to the countries i think it's
an integration of the three countries
and beyond that provides the safest
guarantee for egypt for sudan and the
rest of the
the uriparian countries there is a
mechanism isn't there that's supposed to
be handling uh
negotiations to resolve the matter
through the au
has the au proved though that it's not
very effective in managing this one
yes uh sami the au unfortunately it's
not nice to say that but has failed
uh in many many fronts in the bus i mean
they have been involved in this uh on
and off on and off but they have not
succeeded
either to
just even succeed to bring these three
people to
to so i mean the two points uh alex
mentioned them are the st too sticking
point the sudanese want to be assured
technically is not going to flood and
kill their people and the egyptian need
to be assured there will not be any time
where the serbian can stop or reduce
their share of water so how do you
resolve this symbol it has to be a legal
binding agreement
i know there is a loss of historical
agreement between sudan and
ibrahimosubia let's forget all that
saying one now where it can
symbolize saying ethiopia in the future
cannot
change or reduce or do anything or block
water from egypt and then sudan will
need to be given the opportunity to
evaluate and see and be assured this dam
is going to bring them loss of benefit
such as
regulating of the flood of the water it
will minimize flooding love love all
this all this boy unless this has been
happening i don't think it will happen
uh african union unfortunately has has
proven from time to time its failure uh
it's uh there's lots of geopolitics in
africa itself uh and i think uh the fact
abhi ahmad is very significant in within
the african union again uh
the egyptian president is quite
significant in the african unions which
left sudan out particularly when you
have three bars one of them is quite
weak and two are very significant you
can't get to the legal agreement so i
think
in a simple answer the african union had
failed and i do think it can resolve
this issue as soon as possible which we
all wanted uh and also don't forget we
are talking about
one of the largest can it be resolved
without greater buy-in and involvement
by world powers who right now frankly
might be too busy with what's going on
on the ukraine-russia border
absolutely you're right i think this is
other thing the rest of the world is
very busy with many things
i'm sure you follow the geopolitics in
the uk in america and so on sudan
unfortunately now is more of negli uh
start to be neglected by the rest of the
world
uh egypt is is having their own uh
agendas now so i think yes uh the
pandemic other geopolitics other
important issues is taking attention all
right really on the side of helping
countries to come to it we've just got a
few minutes left i'm going to try and
bring adam back in and say
how realistic
are the expectations that this could be
a game changer for the whole continent
the ethiopian talk about this will
provide electricity
not only for ethiopia but for sudan for
kenya for other countries
um well quickly i think so you know the
african union indeed has not been able
to secure an agreement but i think we
have to recognize that the primary
responsibility lies on the three
countries and if the three countries are
not willing to compromise then the
african there is very little that the
african union can do um and even though
the united states has tried it russia
has tried it you know superpowers have
the potential to influence the direction
of the agreement but ultimately the
responsibility for success or failure of
negotiations lies with the three
countries in terms of its potential i
think it's massive um you know
economically uh it's it's gonna generate
more than five thousand uh kilowatts of
of of energy and part of that will be
exported to sudan there is already
process going on um and of course i
think that symbolically the the ability
of a country to self-finance a massive
project as as as gerd i think it sends a
massive signal for the continent uh in
terms of self self self reliance let me
know so it is an economic opportunity
and a social opportunity potential game
changer we've got a minute though alex
do you agree with that could this be the
project that turns africa into an
electricity export or even to europe are
some of the claims from ethiopia
i i i think what this does what this
crisis does and this and and
and and the potential does is it
refocuses attention on the need for an
integrated economic and political and
peace and security architecture not just
for the horn of africa but for the horn
of africa and the middle east and that
is a a challenge that was encapsulated
in the the original conception the
renaissance of of of africa which has to
be now you know 10 years on be
reinvented for the the current situation
of of of turmoil and disorder
all right we're going to have to leave
it there because we are out of time but
let's thank our guests adam cassie abbey
and alex davao
and thank you to for watching the show
you can see it again anytime by visiting
our website
aljazeera.com for further discussion
head over to our facebook page that's
facebook.com forward slash aj inside
story you can also join the conversation
on twitter our handle there is at aj
inside story from me sami zaydan and the
whole team here for now it's goodbye